pour vous parler de la confiance
j'ai choisi voix des poètes
la poésie nous apprend que que nous
avons de plus intime est en fait le plus
partagé l'intimité voie vers l'ultime
l'intime comme voie de l' intime
je fais le pari alors ce soir que mon
chemin personnel d'apprivoisement de la
confiance vous permettra de baliser le
vôtre sûrement différent mais peut-être
pas si différent que ça
alors en réfléchissant à ce qui m'était
arrivé pour conquérir la confiance j'ai
repéré cinq choses qui me semblait
importante
la confiance se construit
à travers les joies et des épreuves de
la vie dans une démarche interarabe
l'aller la confiance se forge aussi dans
le regard des autres
la confiance
nous permettent d'aller vers ceux et
celles qu'on aime
elle sublime quelque chose de la haine
en osant la fierté
et puis elle nous invite aussi à
cultiver l'altérité mais avant de vous
partager quelques poésies pour vous
parler de ça
accordez-moi que la confiance elle nous
renvoie aussi à nos toutes premières
fois
alors pour commencer ce soir
je vais vous partagez la toute première
chanson que j'ai écrite il y à 40 ans
bientôt 40 ans j'avais 15 ans et je ne
savais pas que cette chanson serait en
quelque sorte une clé pour aller vers
les autres tout au long de ma vie comme
sur un fil
[Musique]
au court toujours après quelque chose ou
quelqu'un le funambule qui vit temps
nous espère encore espère malgré tout en
demain désire enfin que son fils ne
casse pas trop tôt bien alors qu'ils ne
tombent pas de trop qu'il se rattrape
avec les mains
tu peux toujours croire espérer se
laisser porter où vouloir que ce qui
n'est pas mort s'achève que ce qui est
mort vive je te donne ma volonté tu
finira bien par pouvoir tranquillement
de dégager en prenant le temps de
respirer
en court toujours après quelque chose
quelqu'un
c'est souvent une question de temps se
plaît parfois
endormi on se complaît parfois aussi
dans son malheur en attendant on regarde
parfois
fatigué sa propre vie qui se défait on
ne veut plus rien retenir on n'en peut
plus
de voir venir
toujours après quelque chose quelqu'un
la vie des autres
toute façon nous paraîtra toujours plus
simple puisqu'on n'aura pas à la vivre
puisqu'on aura qu'à la comprendre mais
lentement nous comblerons les fossés qui
rendent impossible une vraie rencontre
pour rire et même
espérer nous entendre
mon porte jaune après quelque chose ou
quelqu'un
on court toujours après quelque chose ou
[Musique]
dans mon expérience la confiance se
construit dans une démarche intérieure
et les conquêtes sur les blessures de la
vie
à sept ans j'ai perdu ma soeur
ces épreuves que l'enfant traverse il
les dépasse comme il peut dans une
descente intérieure que je crois
vraiment spirituel
tout à fait propre autant de l'enfance
le temps de l'inutile
notre enfant souffre encore de ses
douleurs d'enfant on peut rire oublié
avoir honte se mentir notre enfant
souffre encore de ses douleurs d'enfant
tu peux dire j'ai grandi tu peux dire
j'ai plus mal tu peux dire c'est promis
tu peux dire c'est normal avec le temps
l'enfant se guérit de l'enfance et même
l'adolescent désapprend ses souffrances
il range ses révoltes il est devenu
grand
isle en terre en l'adulte tous ses
chagrins dans le temps
d'où vient alors parfois
le sentiment curieux d'être sur la même
pente de vivre encore une fois est bien
qu'on soit pluvieux
ce chagrin qui nous hante dont on
connaît le goût mais que l'on oubliera
jusqu'au prochain voyage au prochain
rendez vous au timbre d'une voix un
nouveau visage au jeu c'est le parfum de
l'infinie tristesse qui nous rattrape
par où nous étions certains que notre
vieillesse aurait été remparts
qui oublie les injures qui oublie les
chagrins
comment masquer la perte
ne serait pas par jour en pensant qu'un
matin l'enfance nous désert amis
se souvient-il du temps de ton enfance
le long temps de l'ennui tu étais sur
ton il tu étais en vacances
attendaient la sortie
comme il durait ce temps ils te donnait
la chance en perte ou en profite
d'apprivoiser le vent de soigner ta
souffrance de préparer ta vie
c'est ce temps qui nous manque c'est ce
temps qu'on oublie c'est l'instant qui
répare nos souffrances et nous flanque
notre envie d'être en vie c'est
l'instant qui sépare c'est le temps de
l'enfance le temps de l'inutile du
passage et des seuils c'est l'appel que
nous lance notre enfant sur son île
pour guérir de ses deuils
et puis la confiance se forge aussi dans
le regard des autres plusieurs speaker
on expliquer ça on n'a jamais confiance
en soi tout seul
l'humanité est un collectif qui doit
nous laisser une place et que nous
devons prendre nous avons je crois
besoin d'un peu de regards de quelques
personnes qui comptent pour nous de
regard d'amour
trois femmes m'ont permis de me diriger
vers l'art
elle s'appelait anne louise et
marguerite sans doute vous en
reconnaîtrez l'une ou l'autre
elles ont changé ma vie
j'ai tant aimé ces femmes qu'elles ont
changé ma vie c'est l'éternelle histoire
louise tue elle absente inconnu la fidl
tuez-les indépendante tueur est la plus
belle
tu fus la malheureuse tu reste
silencieuse ton visage illumine l'écran
noir de mai elle ta solitude ces graines
dans un collier de perles louise tue
elle absente l'inconnu la fidl
marguerite a rejoint louise en paradis
elle a tissé des liens pour me donner
raison elle a tissé de loin ma vie avec
sa vie elle a jeté des ponts d'alexis à
zénon je suis fils de la terre et du
ciel étoilé marguerite a rejoint louise
au paradis
j'étais enchanté sylvestre j'étais
enchanté soeur anne que mes chansons
toujours semble boire à sa source tout
ce que je peux être se rattachent à
cette âme
j'aime les gens qui doutent et vendent
la peau de l'ours et puis des
troubadours à calamity jane j'étais
enchanté sylvestre j'étais enchanté
soeur anne j'ai tant aimé ces femmes
la confiance
est aussi un chemin vers celles et ceux
que nous aimons
oser dire jeu dans le monde du haut qui
nous paraît souvent si loin du nôtre
surtout comme si dans mon cas le on
parle en permanence de moi parle
insultes
oui par l'insultent petites lettres
écrites à mes parents à dix sites à 17
ans qui commence avec l'aide de liliane
wouters une poétesse belge qui dit que
pour vivre il faut planter un arbre il
faut faire un enfant
bâtir une maison
j'ai seulement regarder l'eau qui passe
pour nous disant que tout c'est cool
j'ai seulement chercher le feu qui brûle
en nous disant que tout s'éteint
j'ai seulement suivi et le vent qui fuit
en nous disant que tout se perd je n'ai
rien se met dans la terre qui reste en
nous disant
je vous attends
j'aurais tellement voulu vous ramener un
soir cette fille attendu que je
n'attendais pas
j'aurais tellement voulu vous offrir la
joie de parents devenu tout d'un coup
grands parents
j'ai peur que mes enfants ne soient pas
de cela qu'on fait avec une autre si
vous saviez le temps qu'on passe à se
débattre à refuser le vent a lutté
contre soi
si vous saviez les larmes que l'on verse
parfois pour s'interdire de vivre ce que
l'on est
j'aurais vraiment voulu pouvoir vivre
comme vous vous offrir une vie que vous
auriez comprise a comme j'aurais voulu
que vous fussiez de moins aussi fier que
moi je pu l'être de vous
comme j'aurais voulu que mes amours ne
soit celle qu'on doit comprendre
ne m'imaginais pas plus malheureux que
vous la souffrance est souvent la libye
du mensonge on pardonne aux souffrants
qu'on n'a pas à aimer moi je veux votre
amour pas votre compassion
je rêve à un regard qui serait sans
idées
et sans indifférence
mais vous savez le temps passé à se
débattre
et dites-moi aux dites moi que vous
resterez là
à propos d' insulte
quel est le contraire de la confiance
pour moi un truc hybride qui s'enracine
dans la peur le cynisme et l'égoïsme
quelque chose qui appelle à une
sublimation pour guérir de la mer
car sans la confiance le monde du haut
ont toujours si loin du nôtre pourrait
bien nous conduire à la haine
la confiance alors
sublime quelque chose de la haine en
osant la fierté car vous savez
la haine de l'autre prend tout son temps
la haine de l'autre prend tous les gants
de boxe de velours sourire aux dents ce
masque du doute bien poliment
j'avais rêvé d'un monde meilleur où l'on
vivrait cent comparé où l'humain
seraient frères ou soeurs j'avais rêvé
frères ou soeurs de symboliser mais la
haine de l'autre
faut-il rebrousser le chemin
faut-il oublier l'avenir
faut-il embrassé cette haine qui tend la
main
désirante qu'on l'a désir car la haine
de l'autre
ou faut-il vivre ce mépris et transformé
ma est nantes faut-il que ce regard de
lyme soit aussi de la mort un désir qui
monte de ma mort le désir qui monte si
la haine de l'autre
je passerai votre chemin
mène deviendra ma fierté mieux vaut
encore c'est mais que de vous détestez
je préfère marcher vers demain je
préfère marcher vers demain quand la
haine de l'autre
perdra son temps la haine de l'autre
sera sans gants quand chacun saura
reconnaître en soit la haine de l'autre
alors on aimera on refusera toujours à
la fois la haine de l'autre la haine de
soi
la confiance pour terminer dans mon
expérience que je voulais vous partagez
en tout cas demande une certaine
vigilance pour cultiver l'altérité
pour finir je voudrais citer anne
sylvestre mon ami qui est morte il ya
juste un an
avec des beaucoup d'émotion mais aussi
de gratitude
massera nous rappelle que la confiance
se construit en cultivant son
indispensable complément
c'est pour paraphraser saint thomas
d'aquin on pourrait dire qu'il lui parle
de la foi et de la raison mais on
pourrait dire que la confiance et le
doute doivent cheminer comme deux
affectionner
anne sylvestre en a fait une très très
belle chanson dont je donne un tout
petit extrait pour terminer
j'aime les gens qui doutent les gens qui
trompait coûte leur coeur se balancer
j'aime les gens qui disaient qui se
contredisent et sans se dénoncer j'aime
les gens qui te semble que parfois il
nous semble capable de juger j'aime les
gens qui passent moitié dans leurs
godasses et moitié à côté
j'aime leur petite chanson
même s'il passe pour des cons
[Musique]
j'aime les gens qui doutent mais
voudrait qu'on leur foute la paix de
temps en temps et qu'on ne les malmène
jamais quand ils promènent leur automne
au printemps qu'on leur dise que l'amf
ait plus belles flammes que tout c'est
triste qu et pour les remercier en leur
disons leur crient merci d'avoir vécu
même si
pour la tendresse
et tant pis pour nos fesses
qui ont fait
ce qu'elles ont pu
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]